hello again everybody
my name is Alex Chisholm I'm on the
posit Cloud team here at posit
thank you for joining us for this third
episode in our live demo Series today
we're going to turn to a new feature
that we put into the product in the
middle or late uh August called project
templates
and what project templates enable you to
do is speed up your workflows when you
have a core set of of items think that
you want to put in the same project over
and over and over again we make it easy
to surface those and we're going to take
a look at that today
so you probably are aware for those of
you who have joined before once you're
on positive Cloud it's pretty easy to
start a new project
typically you're going in and you're
just clicking new project and you're
creating either a blank R Studio project
or a Jupiter notebook project maybe
you're pulling something in uh from from
GitHub from a GitHub repo and what we've
added to this flow is this ability to
create a new project from a template
there are several circumstances right
where this functionality might be useful
to you because every time on positive
Cloud you're creating a new project it's
really a blank canvas a blank slate it's
up to you to decide which packages to
install which data connections to make
and what you can do with the template if
you find yourself with a recurring uh
workflow maybe you always use the same
set of packages maybe you need to bring
in you know data sets or flat files you
know that don't change very often you
want them to be used across all of your
projects
maybe you know that the that a certain
type of project is going to have a lot
more compute requirements and you want
to be able to set your memory or your
CPU at a higher at a higher level
or maybe you just want to get into some
of those those uh fine details that you
might find in something like project
settings in the r Studio IDE and you
want this to come up every single time
that you're opening this new project
so this is what project templates enable
you to do
and there are two ways for you to start
interacting with templates on positive
Cloud today
the first one is you have the ability to
select from I think six predefined
pre-configured templates that have been
put together by by thought leaders and
experts around posit and that are now on
positive cloud
so that's the first way it helps you get
started more quickly you can see some
examples see some sample code data sets
and I have all the libraries and
packages you need uh to work on those
workflows without setting up stuff on
your uh for yourself
secondly you have the ability to design
your own template
and this is the one that's going to
become more powerful the more you use it
I believe so here you're going to be
able to create a new project do
everything you need to do based upon you
know those four items we mentioned on
the previous slide and then you're going
to be able to call this template again
and again and again when you're doing
subsequent work
and we're also going to see the ability
to make what you do in this template to
default anytime you start a new project
from within that space
so as we're going along here we do have
q a open up I'll probably jump in at the
end and answer anything specific that
comes in if I don't see it while we're
going through it but right now I'm going
to hop over uh to a free account on
buzzer cloud
okay you should be able to see my screen
now there it is
and I'm going to hop off and we're just
going to go into housing.cloud
for those of you who might be new
um who need help getting started all you
have to do is click on get started
you'll see a variety of ways that you
can engage with positive Cloud again I'm
going to go ahead and use a free account
today which I've already created on this
on this machine
so if I log in I'm just going to go out
to Google here
it's going to authenticate and bring me
into the product
and the first thing you're always going
to find right is this this your
workspace and from your workspace you
see the button that I looked at on the
previous slide talking about what that
new project would be and you can see
that now we have this additional new
project from template
so if this is your first time if you
click on new rstudio project or New
Jupiter project you're pretty much
getting just the basic components of
what you would have without any
additional packages installed really
just what you need to to get started and
get running if you include if you click
on new projects from a git repo you're
going to be able to go ahead and bring
something in from GitHub which would
automatically create that rstudio
project for you
and what we're going to look at today is
new project from template so if I click
on this
you're going to have a lot of options
come up on your screen
and you can see that we're saying that
you want to create a new project from a
template here the list of available
templates within your space right now
and these are all put together by us
from posit cloud
so maybe you're interested in doing some
machine learning with tidy models or you
want to do some publishing maybe with
quarto or you want to make an
application with shiny with the shiny
app all of these are going to bring in
all of the libraries associated with
some of the sample code that we have in
here for you
and I know many people on the call are
Educators and when you're working with
students maybe before the semester and
you want them to get started it's kind
of hard for them to create a new project
because they don't know how to interact
with you know r or Jupiter from clicking
on on one of these they're going to get
set up in a way where they're going to
have something to play around with and
click with immediately
so let's go ahead and click on data
analysis in our with the Tidy verse
I'm going to click ok
and it's going to create a new project
for me
and let's just call this let's just call
this tidy verse
it takes around 15 to 20 seconds to
create a new instance uh for the
specific R Studio project
and because we created one through a
template here we're going to see a
variety of files
um in here when we first get started
so this this sample template will notice
a few things when we go over to the
files pane
the first is that we have a data folder
all right so we've got some data that's
already in here in CSV format
we also have a qmd project
and a readme.qmd
all of the all of the templates are
going to come with this readme file and
it's just going to give you a little bit
of background about what you can expect
from the code and packages that that
happen to be in here so in this case
we're going to go out and explore some
languages spoken in the United States
you're going to be able to run some code
in the specific file languages.qmd
tell us a little bit about the data that
is available in that folder and all the
files are in there and then which
packages have been included already from
within this template so you can get to
work right away without having to
install all of these
so let's click on that file
languages.qmd
all right so we've got a quarto document
that's what the qmd is for those people
who have used our markdown in the past
this is kind of the Next Generation
Um of that of that tooling that we're
really uh pleased with at posit I'm
going to go ahead and render this in my
viewer pane so that we all can see it uh
relatively easily and there's not a
pop-up that might come out from the
window that I'm sharing here so if I go
ahead and render this
once again without bringing in any
additional libraries or packages we're
going to be able to see you know the
analysis that came from uh this this
workflow we went out we read in the path
for where our data is we started to do
some exploration see what the main
variables look like and the top records
are
group things together so we're looking
at all the languages we're trying to
find out how what is the most common
language spoken aside from English and
then we get to the point where we're
doing some visualization right some
Spanish Portuguese Portuguese and
Chinese is coming from this data set you
get the idea we're just doing basic
exploratory analysis here based upon a
predefined set of data and packages
associated with this
so this is using something provided by
posit Cloud if I go back to your
workspace
you're going to see that now what was
the template is saved as a a piece of
content a project I can play with these
settings a little bit so I already named
it the tidyverse demo when I went in
maybe I don't want this description to
change anymore maybe I just want to do
you know language analysis
we can customize it we can decide who
gets to see it and who doesn't right now
I'll just leave this private
but you can see that we took a
predefined template created by posit
cloud and we let you the users save this
as a new project from which you have all
those assets that came from it
and now this is just a regular project
as you would have seen before
and what I want to do here you'll notice
one thing when I click on new project
and new project from template
it's only from positive cloud
what we have the ability to do within a
shared space is have you defined a
template of your own and then have you
and others that maybe are members of
your space come in and start using those
those customized designed templates
so let's create a new space
and we will call this
shared space Maybe
we've created a new space
as we've talked about in the last live
demo where we did a deep dive on what it
means to be within a space versus a
personal workspace you know two of the
main major differences at the top here
at least where the ability to store data
connections and to have member
management
so you maybe you want to bring in a few
more people into your space that you're
collaborating with uh that that is that
is fine but what we're going to do is
take a look at the template flow here
which is slightly different
when you click on new project and do a
new project from template
now you're going to see the same set of
six templates from positive Cloud that
you could use in the same way that you
were doing it in your personal workspace
but you also can see well you could have
some templates coming in from this
specific workspace that we named shared
space
and we're telling you that there are no
templates available at the moment so
let's go ahead and create one so that
we're able to come back here and pull it
up
so to do this the first thing we're
going to do is create a new project
and let's call this you know marketing
analysis
maybe we have new data that comes in
every month we want to be able to run
some analysis on it we've got a core set
of data that we're going to append to
here we've got some libraries that we
use
so when you click on packages just as a
as an aspiration my guess is that many
of you on the call are used to using
right the Tidy verse in uh in a lot of
your workflows
because of the way posit Cloud works
every time we create a new project
you're getting essentially this Blank
Slate this blank canvas so something
like tidyburst won't be there
so what we can do is to install packages
I'm just going to bring in the Tidy
verse
go out and it'll take you know about a
minute to to pull together everything
because of course we're getting you know
ggplot2 and we're getting D plier and a
bunch of other helper functions that are
part of that that tidy verse
so we're going to go out and this is
going to expand the packages that we
have in our space
while we're working on that you know
maybe we do have a
a data file that we're going to want in
all of our subsequent analysis within
the space so maybe I can upload a data
file here
I'll just go out and grab a quick one
that I've got on my desktop desktop
called marketing
and we can see that now we've got a
marketing CSV file uh that is quite
small
so so far we've added a package the Tidy
verse in this case if I go back to
packages now I'll be able to see the
Tidy versus available for us to to load
in and our list of packages has expanded
widely
uh something else we might want to do
maybe maybe we want you know a recurring
script so maybe we want just a very
basic
eda.r where I'm going to go out
oh the Tidy Birds Maybe
there now we've got that and taking a
glimpse or a look at our data set
so I'm going to go to my data folder and
I think I named it marketing.csv
oh sorry
uh first we're going to read this in
free TSB I'll just name this my data
frame
yeah
we brought this in now I'm going to go
take a look at that data frame that I
brought in
and we can see the types of variables
that are in this relatively uh
relatively small data set but it does
have 39 columns so it's fairly large and
we can see that we have the income of a
specific person how many kids are in the
home how many teenagers are the home and
maybe this is something that is part of
a constant flow that we're always
pulling in as sort of a starting point
within our analysis
so now we've brought in packages we've
brought in data we've created a script
the other thing that we could do through
templates is change our compute
resources
so one thing that is unique about
positive cloud is our ability at the
project and output level to determine
how much memory we want to use and how
much compute we want to use and then
finally what the background execution
time is meaning if you're not
interacting with your with your console
how long will the project keep going to
work on some of these backward
background tabs I'm sitting in a free
account here so it's going to tell me I
can't go above one CPU or one gigabyte
of ram but if you were on a basic or a
standard or any other paid plan you'll
have the ability to increase these save
them and then come back to this as a
template without having everything kind
of put together in the current form
so now that we've gone through and and
bringing brought in all of these new
components let's go back to our space
we see that we still just have this
private marketing analysis project that
we created
but let's turn this into a template
if I click on dot dot dot and click
settings
uh again I can add a description I could
I could change the name but if I go over
to access
I could keep it private for myself like
if I'm the only person in this space and
I wanted to use this template myself I
could if I do bring in new space members
if I want them and I want them to be
able to uh be able to interact and use
the template as well I need to make it
available for everybody
and then I then we can look at special
access here
and there's a new check box called Mark
this make this project a template
so let's start with this
I'll close this the first thing that we
see is that we have a template tag that
is now on the project
it's going to fall within that template
folder so I can know how many are within
my space
and now the fun part the useful part is
when you or anyone else that you've
invited to be a member of your space
creates a new project from template
now we have this marketing analysis uh
template there for us to create a new
project
so if I go ahead and create click ok
and this could be you know now we're
gonna do our October 2023
and Reporting
but because all of those things that we
did the first iteration we added
packages we added a data set we added a
script we could have changed our compute
resources I don't want to have to do
that every single time that I'm that I'm
operating here
this should bring in the right files
that we added so we can see that we have
eda.r
we can see that we have that Baseline in
our marketing data set that we use as a
as a starting point for a lot of our
analysis
when I go ahead and try to run Library
tidy verse it's going to go ahead and
load because it's already been
configured with everything that we
included within that template
so now in terms of all the content we
have we just have one derived project
from that template
and we have
um the template that that we had the
project that we marked as a template
which then continues to serve as a
starting point for other people who want
to start something new
the final thing we can talk through here
before we get into some q a about about
the new feature or positive cloud in
general
is if I were to create a new project a
new R Studio project right now or a new
Jupiter project right now both would
continue to be blank
so templates give you the ability right
to have a specific one based on certain
workflows to help you get started faster
and then reuse them when you find
yourself with recurring or repetitive
work
what you're also able to do if you know
that you're always going to use you know
let's say the Tidy verse right we can
also take the template oops we can take
the template
over here marketing analysis and go back
to the dot dot dot
when I click on access I can see that
this already is you know the template
it's the one that we use to create the
subsequent project I can also go one
step further and say make this the
default rstudio template meaning every
time that anybody within your space
creates new project
they're always going to get whatever was
included within this project
so now if I come back here
and I click on new project
this and every other new one that you
would be able to to create you should
have those same assets that we looked at
before
so I've created from
default
once we get verification that we have
the assets coming through from here
we've sort of covered the three
different ways that we can use
templating
to get up and running more quickly on
PODS of cloud and there you see we've
got the the scripts we've got the data
files and the library should be there as
well
so let me I'll keep this open for now
and then we will turn over to q a my
colleague Hannah is here to to work with
us through that and we can go back into
the IDE or positive Cloud if we need to
look at something specific
awesome thanks Alex uh we had a couple
of questions come in throughout the
presentation so I'm just gonna start
going through them
um I think Jeff asked a clarifying
question he said so every time I make a
project composite Cloud I have to
download and install packages
yeah that's that's that's the case and
the way that we set this up right is we
want each and every space and each and
every project to be kind of a standalone
entity where you have total control over
what's in there and that includes
packages so what this features this
feature enables you to do from a variety
of ways is say well I will I don't want
to download something every time if I
know I'm going to use it every time so
we can either create a template for that
or we can turn that into a default
template where you don't even need to
think about starting a new project flow
through that templating functionality
you're just getting those packages off
the bat without having to install again
and again
James asked are we able to connect to
Azure SQL
yes you should be able to let's go let's
go over here so in essence anything that
you can connect through uh connect to
Via the r Studio IDE you should be able
to do it through posit Cloud as well
the one thing that we had it
specifically in terms of data
connections uh more recently and I think
this came out in May was the ability for
positive Cloud to securely store your
credentials for certain data connections
um for which posit maintains a set of
professional drivers to help make this
connection easier for you
so I don't think Azure ml is going to be
here directly but you can see I think 16
of the most common database uh
connections that that are out there and
if I click on postgres I can save all of
my credentials and I can bring this in
through the project
so even though Azure ml is not here when
you're within your project if you can
find a way through our studio through a
package or another driver that might be
included to make that connection that
flow would also work through posit cloud
awesome
related
um can you make and use a project
template only in posit cloud or can you
do that within the desktop app
no yeah right now this is all product
project posit Cloud specific
um in terms of functionality so both the
data connections and the templating are
proprietary in some ways uh to pause the
cloud at the moment and what we're
trying to do is we're trying to add you
know some bells and whistles around the
Baseline functionality of the Standalone
Ides in a way that carries through
throughout the the products you're able
to go between a a template or a data
connection and these projects and
outputs in the same space
question over and
over on system level libraries from the
terminal would they be captured in a
template yes they should everything
comes over that you see including
project settings from within a project
the one thing that does not carry over
at the moment or any global settings
that you may have made within the rst
studio IDE those will not carry through
to a new template
will templates for Jupiter projects be
available in the future
we have definitely been considering this
um and and we've had on our roadmax some
road map some python work for for a
while you've probably noticed when I'm
going here to new project from template
we do have a templating here so let's go
ahead and click this up but I'm in a I'm
not in a free account let me let me
switch over to my other screen for a
moment okay
I think we can take a look at this
yeah so now I'm in my my posit account
I'm in my personal workspace I'm going
to go ahead and create
that pandas template so we have the
ability to create this from uh from the
global pot the global templates put
together by posit
Ive so this would be Jupiter template
yeah and this was worked on by Dan
within our company uh going out and
putting together some sample data files
and the ability to go through and use
pandas to do some basic data analysis so
once again here we're able to save the
Penguins clean we're able to find a
penguins clean CSV we can go into Eda
and without downloading or installing
any of this let's run it to make sure
that it works
but I've gone through and I've loaded in
the required libraries
and I can come through right away and
see I'm able to connect to that data set
and put together a table like this let's
go out to your to your initial question
let's go out and create a new shared
space
uh let's see
Jupiter
template testing
I'm going to create this
let's make a new project through Jupiter
because I think through this now and I'm
thinking this actually will work in
terms of setting up and saving a project
from from Jupiter as well
oh that's interesting I think if I just
refresh it'll come up
there we go so test template
and let's go here ahead here and maybe
do a new
um
let's see a new notebook we'll use
python 3.10
just a test this year I'm just going to
name this you know load pandas
go back to
make sure that it is saved
I'll go back here and we see that we
have load pandas here even though we
haven't brought in any specific uh
packages at the moment so let me go back
now to our space
if I click on settings dot dot dot and
access we can see that we can make this
this project template
I'll go ahead and make it available to
anybody who happens to be within my
space
I can also make it the Jupiter default
so it looks like we do have full
functionality here in terms of the
Jupiter side for for templating and then
we can validate this
by now going back to new project
create a new project from template and
we'll find that within this space we had
our test template that we just put
together
so for those of people who do have a
paid plan or working with like in a
university setting with professors who
have a paid plan you should be able to
also create Jupiter templates both from
the global posit Cloud templates as well
as setting their setting their own
let's just wait for this to come up to
verify completely but I think it should
work and here we go this was the
template that we created where we just
went out and we made a quick notebook
and we brought in pandas
so that does it looks like it is working
the next one can I use templates with
data connections
yeah totally
um so we I looked at the the data
connection feature with you a few
moments ago we're just going through and
we're making this connection if you were
going to be able to use those within one
of the templates that you're defining as
long as that initial data connection
still exists within that space they'll
be able to carry through and be used
through templates
then Cedric
of observe event as a template this
template Works in my own our studio
Workshop environment but it fails to
react in the posit Cloud environment
so I think the question is any ideas on
why that might be so an observed event
within shiny I'm assuming uh this one's
a little bit harder to to diagnose off
the spot but feel free to to email me at
alex.chism at posit.com I'd be glad to
work through with that and find out you
know what might be happening there
perfect
so right now that wraps up all the
questions that we got for today so
unless any come in last minute
um we'll wrap up but thank you all for
joining thank you Alex uh for showing us
how to use templates and just reminder
that we do these events every month on
the last Tuesday of the month so you can
check back in and we'll be covering
another posit Cloud feature or use case
uh in October so thank you all for
joining thank you Alex and see you next
time
sounds good thanks everyone